okay yesterday we talked about Donald
Trump rescinding daca and it was so
funny yesterday I was teaching the the
class that I teach as adjunct faculty at
Boston College and we were doing
evaluating the strength of arguments and
we had a hypothetical argument which
said since Donald Trump wants to get rid
of daca he doesn't care about the future
of immigrant children and of course
that's not a really strong argument it's
possible that Donald Trump doesn't
realize that scrapping daca would hurt
immigrant children this was a
hypothetical that we talked about in
class and yet according to a new report
it appears Donald Trump truly didn't
realize what would happen if he
rescinded daca which he said he would
yesterday according to the New York
Times as this entire thing was
developing Trump administration
officials were worried that Donald Trump
didn't realize what would happen if he
rescinded daca to put it another way
Donald Trump made a major decision about
policy without understanding what it
meant or the implications here's a quote
from the New York Times yesterday the
blame averse president told a confidant
over the past few days that he realized
that he had gotten himself into a
politically untenable position as late
as one hour before the decision was to
be announced administration officials
privately expressed concern that mr.
Trump might not fully grasp the details
of the steps he was about to take and
when he discovered their full impact
would change his mind according to a
person familiar with their thinking who
was not authorized to comment on it and
spoke on the condition of anonymity but
ultimately the president followed
through on his campaign pledge at the
urging of Jeff sessions and other
hardline members in his White House
including Stephen Miller
his top domestic adviser is anyone
shocked and some people say he's been
talking about daca since the campaign so
clearly he understands it Trump's been
talking about health care since the
beginning of his campaign we found out a
couple months ago he didn't seem to know
the difference between life insurance
and health insurance this is not at all
shocking if true that Trump had no idea
what would happen if he rescinded daca
you know yesterday we were wondering why
Jeff Sessions went out there to make the
announcement and the White House press
secretary secretary Huckabee Sanders
said that it was because a legal matter
and they didn't really think it was
constitutional so that's why they sent
sessions out there
we were thinking maybe it was just Trump
being cowardly and wanted sessions to be
thrown under the bus to take the
political hit yeah but now it just seems
as if Trump just didn't know what he was
talking about and even though you know
you'd be reading off a piece of paper or
teleprompter
he couldn't even BS his way through that
he also might have not thought of it as
a big enough deal to go out there
himself
he's like now that we're just rescinding
daca I mean it doesn't really change
anything for anybody so we'll just send
Jeff Sessions out there it's also funny
from that quote that there were advisors
who were thinking if we can get Trump to
understand this then he'll change his
mind
that is not how Donald Trump makes
decision any advisor who still thinks if
we just explain it better to Donald
Trump then he'll change his mind you've
not been paying attention for the last
seven plus months of Donald Trump's
administration silver lining it appears
Trump didn't go with the last piece of
advice someone whispered into his ear
that's the only silver lining I can
possibly find it seems like he's stuck
with something
despite the most recent influence
attempts that he might have received
from his advisors if you were brought to
the US as a kid it's wrong to deport you
since you did nothing wrong you were
brought by your parents that's the big
picture sometimes to understand an issue
you've got to go into the details
sometimes to understand an issue you've
got to go to the big picture here it's
the big picture and this is an absolute
and total disaster just knowing the
mindset of Stephen Miller and Jeff
Sessions is it's no surprise that they
would be pushing for something like this
and that's why it's unfortunate that
Donald Trump is so easily convinced by
these people you know in a leadership
position you have to be able to listen
to a bunch of different perspectives and
choose the best one yes not just
whoever's the last in the room I think
President Obama for all of his faults he
was able to do that which is to soberly
take advice from dissenting individuals
in some cases and formulate on his own
what really makes sense
you can't delegate out every
responsibility you have to know the
policy by yourself that's right david
pakman.com slash read it discuss this
and any other issues from today's show
with us today's program is made possible
in part by Gamefly which is sort of like
netflix for video games they've got over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3
we and a bunch of other platforms and
you can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30-day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s